unfortunately a lot of it's going to be
undone i hope some of the peace deals
last
but the trouble is that biden is very
likely going to re-enter the the
awful iran deal and that's probably
going to destabilize the region further
joe biden utterly utterly beholden to
the foreign policy establishment which
is probably going to be want to be more
provocative in the middle east
president trump one of his great
accomplishments was sort of routing the
foreign policy establishment
that probably gone the abortion policy
obviously gone
many many many of the executive orders
going to be gone
a lot of that is about to be undone
even down to the white house website i i
was looking yesterday
online sort of sitting in the hospital
room with my newborn child
let's see is it all crazy already
on the white house website they've
already gotten rid of the 1776
commission
which was an answer to the 1619 project
1619 project says america's evil and
awful and terrible
trump comes in and says we need a 1776
commission biden already got rid of that
he said we need to
we need to keep people thinking america
is rotten and terrible first thing
second thing on the white house website
you now
have to insert your pronouns when you
contact the white house you can say
she her he him they them other you can
say that you prefer not to share your
pronouns
still a choice on the list they don't
unfortunately have she him
what if in the nominative i want to be a
woman but in the accusative i want to be
a man they don't
permit that hopefully equality will
prevail and we'll get more pronouns
when we're all told biden's a moderate
he's going to unify the country joe
biden on the white house website on day
one
is buying into the most radical sexual
ideology we've ever seen
gender ideology buckle up folks and i
hope you have nothing but scorn
for the fake conservatives who endorsed
this guy
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you